Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Un milliard de tonnes de CO2.
C’est l’addition très salée
et très carbonée de l’aérien chaque année.
Cela représente 2%
des émissions globales de carbone
et deux fois celle de la France.
Il est indéniable qu’on va devoir,
dans les prochaines décennies,
décarboner massivement l’aérien
si on ne veut pas rester cloué au sol.
Les solutions, elles existent.
On a par exemple le SAF, autrement dit
Sustainable Aviation Fuel,
qui vous permet globalement
de faire un Paris New York
avec des déchets recyclés,
type huile de friture,
tous types de déchets agricoles.
Le souci, c’est que la production de SAF
reste extrêmement anecdotique
par rapport au trafic mondial aujourd’hui.
On a l’hydrogène,
mais le souci de l’hydrogène,
c’est qu’il va falloir développer
toute une infrastructure,
des avions à hydrogène,
des stations à hydrogène.
Donc c’est vraiment très long
et très complexe.
Bref, la décarbonation de l'aérien,
c'est long, c'est complexe.
Si, après tout, on n’avait pas pris
le problème du bon côté ?
Si, au lieu d’essayer de décarboner,
on n’essaie pas d’être un peu plus sobre ?
Après tout, l’énergie la plus propre,
c’est celle qu’on ne consomme pas, non ?
Et dans ce milieu de l’aérien,
il y a un véhicule
qui est particulièrement sobre.
C’est le dirigeable.
Un dirigeable, c’est un gros ballon
rempli d’un gaz
qui est plus léger que l’air.
Ça peut être de l’hydrogène
ou de l’hélium.
Il a des moteurs pour pouvoir se diriger -
« dirigeable ».
Il fonctionne comme un bateau des airs.
D’ailleurs, les Anglo-saxons
ont un terme pour le dirigeable
qui est « airship »,
littéralement un bateau des airs.
Le dirigeable, ça a déjà existé.
Le premier dirigeable
est français, d’ailleurs.
Cocorico !
Il s'est envolé dans la forêt de Meudon
en 1884 et s'appelait la France.
On a ensuite utilisé le dirigeable
pour d’autres applications,
notamment pour faire du renseignement
et malheureusement également
pour faire du bombardement.
Et dans les années 30,
on a connu ce qu’on a appelé
l’âge d’or du dirigeable.
On avait des énormes ballons
de plusieurs centaines de mètres
qui étaient utilisés pour des applications
de plus en plus variées.
Des gens faisaient
le tour du monde en ballon.
On avait même des avions qui étaient
catapultés depuis des petits dirigeables.
Et puis cette ère s’est arrêtée
avec un tragique accident
que vous connaissez sûrement.
Le Hindenburg : le 6 mai 1937,
35 personnes meurent
dans l’incendie du Hindenburg.
J’aimerais qu’on s’arrête
deux minutes sur cette photo.
A main levée, qui a vu cette photo ?
Ça fait quand même pas mal de monde,
ça explique pourquoi à 85 ans après,
quand je dis que je fais des dirigeables,
on me dit : « Ah, le truc qui crame. »
Du coup, j’aimerais qu’on s’arrête
un petit peu sur ça.
Pourquoi
le Hindenburg est si connu ?
Pourquoi cette photo est si connue ?
On pourrait dire que c’est parce que
cet accident a été extrêmement meurtrier.
En réalité, « que » 35 morts,
c’est un peu dommage de dire ça comme ça,
mais ce n’est pas du tout l’accident
le plus meurtrier.
Pas non plus le premier.
Il y avait déjà eu d’autres
accidents de dirigeable
et beaucoup d’accidents
d’avion à l’époque.
Pourtant, c’est un des plus connus
parce que c’est un des seuls
dont il reste des traces en fait.
On n’a pas de photo
ou de vidéo du naufrage du Titanic,
on n’a pas de photo ou de vidéo
de naufrage ou de crash d’avion.
Et donc en plus d’avoir des photos,
elles sont spectaculaires.
D’ailleurs LED Zeppelin l’a utilisée
pour faire une super pochette d’album.
C’est vraiment extrêmement
spectaculaire de voir un ballon
qui disparaît littéralement
en moins d’une minute.
Mais est-ce que ça veut dire
que le dirigeable, c’est dangereux ?
Eh bien, vous serez peut-être surpris,
mais à l’époque,
c’était beaucoup plus dangereux
de prendre un avion qu’un dirigeable.
Donc en soi,
le dirigeable n’est pas
intrinsèquement dangereux.
Après, on peut se demander
si le gaz porteur est dangereux.
Il y a deux types de gaz porteurs
qu’on peut utiliser,
l’hydrogène et l’hélium.
L’hydrogène gagne sur pas mal de tableaux.
Il est beaucoup plus léger,
deux fois plus léger.
Il est extrêmement moins cher,
plusieurs dizaines de fois moins cher.
Et il est surtout
beaucoup plus disponible.
L’hydrogène se produit assez facilement
avec de l’électricité et de l’eau.
Tandis que pour faire de l’hélium…
Il y a des réserves d’hélium,
mais c’est un gaz qui est très, très rare.
Le seul moyen de le produire aujourd’hui,
c’est de faire la fusion nucléaire, donc…
Problème.
Mais aujourd’hui, on utilise
principalement de l’hélium,
tout simplement parce que
justement, cet accident-là,
il est resté dans les mémoires
comme « L’hydrogène, c’est dangereux. »
Parce que l’hydrogène, c’est
inflammable.
Après tout, le kérosène aussi,
c’est inflammable !
Les batteries de nos téléphones aussi,
c’est inflammable.
Je vais vous prouver que l’hydrogène,
on peut l’utiliser de manière safe.
Je n’ai même pas besoin de vous le prouver
parce que ça a déjà été fait.
Voilà la course Gordon Bennett.
C’est un peu le Vendée Globe de l’aérien,
ce sont des ballons libres,
pas des ballons dirigeables.
il n’y a pas de moteur.
Ils sillonnent l’Europe
en fonction des vents
et le but est d’arriver le plus loin.
Chaque ballon est rempli
de 1000 mètres cubes d’hydrogène.
Il y a des gens qui montent dedans.
En 64 éditions de la course Gordon
Bennett, il n’y a pas eu un seul incident.
Il y a l'utilisation de l'hydrogène.
Pourquoi ?
Deux exemples.
Vous avez certainement entendu
parler du Triangle du feu :
pour allumer un feu, il faut un comburant,
un combustible et une étincelle.
Là, on élimine deux choses
du triangle du feu.
On n’a pas le comburant
puisque c’est une enveloppe unique,
donc il n’y a pas d’oxygène.
On a des enveloppes
qui sont conductrices d’électricité,
ce qui fait qu’il n’y a pas
d’électricité statique
et donc c’est beaucoup plus safe.
Un dirigeable, ok, à hydrogène, ok,
mais pour quoi faire ?
Il faut savoir que le dirigeable,
il a un prémium à l’économie d’échelle.
C’est pour ça qu’on a vu
des dirigeables énormes,
parce que doubler
la taille d’un dirigeable,
c’est doubler sa performance.
Parce que quand vous doublez
la taille d’un dirigeable,
vous multipliez par quatre la surface,
mais par huit le volume.
Tous les effets positifs d’un dirigeable
viennent de son volume,
donc sa poussée d’Archimède,
et tous les effets négatifs, sa traînée,
son poids d’enveloppe,
eh bien, ça vient de la surface.
Et donc forcément les projets qui existent
à l’heure actuelle pour le dirigeable,
c’est de faire des dirigeables énormes.
Le souci, c’est que ça nécessite
beaucoup d’argent,
un appareil industriel prodigieux
et des compétences
que, malheureusement, on a perdues.
Et c’est en voyant ce problème-là,
qu’on s’est dit qu’il fallait essayer
de trouver un moyen de commencer petit.
Commencer petit n’est pas évident
pour le dirigeable.
Il y a quand même une chose -
Comme je vous ai dit avant,
vu qu’il flotte dans les airs,
on n’a pas besoin d’énergie
pour le maintenir en l’air.
Et donc on peut l’utiliser
comme perchoir sur le monde.
Ça peut peut-être sembler
un peu nébuleux, rêveur,
mais je vais vous donner
juste trois applications
qui ont vraiment beaucoup d’impact.
Les fuites de méthane.
Les fuites de méthane, que ce soit
lors de l’extraction, lors du transport,
lors du raffinage, représentent 5,8%
des émissions de carbone dans le monde.
Trois fois l’aérien.
Et aujourd’hui, le seul outil qu’on a
massivement pour détecter le méthane,
c’est le satellite qui permet de détecter
à peu près 10% des fuites.
Si on avait un dirigeable,
on pourrait faire des centaines
de kilomètres de pipelines,
de raffineries, de tout ce qu’il est
possible d’inspecter
et de trouver nos fuites de méthane.
Le réseau électrique.
Le réseau électrique, c’est la plus grande
machine de l’humanité.
C’est un réseau qui malheureusement
est vieillissant.
Il a pour la plupart été construit
pendant les 30 Glorieuses
et il est de plus en plus mis sous tension
avec l’électrification de notre société.
Donc avoir une plateforme qui permette
d'inspecter ce réseau avec précision,
c'est vraiment important.
Et troisième chose,
les passoires thermiques.
On en parle beaucoup en ce moment.
Le résidentiel, le fait de chauffer
les bâtiments dans le monde,
ça représente 5,5% des émissions de CO2
et c’est souvent dû au fait
qu’il y a beaucoup, beaucoup
de passoires thermiques,
c’est-à-dire des bâtiments
qui sont mal isolés.
Rien qu’en France, il y a 5 millions
de passoires thermiques.
Et donc si finalement c’était ça,
la grande force du dirigeable ?
Pas seulement contribuer
à la décarbonation de l’aérien,
mais offrir une plateforme idéale
pour décarboner la société tout entière.
Merci à tous.
(Applaudissements)